Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von DPU, das Podcast-UFO, euer Lieblings-Podcast-UFO-Podcast. Das klang wie so ein Spruch, DPU, das Podcast-UFO, wir sind wieder da! Wir sind wieder da in der ganzen Galaxie und mit Stefan Tietz ist natürlich dabei, hallo! Stefan Tietz ist natürlich dabei, hallo! Hallo, Stefan Tietz ist natürlich dabei, hallo! Hallo, ihr seid da seit Folge 81. Wir haben es geschafft. Wir haben es geschafft, zwei Wochen nicht zu veröffentlichen. Ja, wir haben es geschafft, ich glaube, die zweitlängste Pause des Podcasts einzulegen. Glaube ich nicht. Glaube ich auch nicht. Es ist viel passiert, beziehungsweise nicht viel passiert. Wir hatten noch nicht wahnsinnig viel Zeit. Viel tut sich gerade, aber ja. Naja, gut. Draußen wird es kälter. Oh Mann, ist das kalt. Das ist so die Dinge, die wir uns mittlerweile zu erzählen haben. Mehr erlebt man halt einfach auch nicht. Beziehungsweise, gut, das ist alles Bürokram, langweiliger Arbeitskram, aber naja, so jetzt eine lustige Anekdote raus.
Boah, letztens, wir haben unsere neuen Bürostühle bekommen und der Stefan hat einen, der quietscht, so wenn man sich zurücklegt und letztens hat er gesagt so, boah, der Gag könnte aber nochmal ein bisschen Schliffiff verlangen. Und dann hat er sich zurückgelegt und dann hat zu laut gequietscht. Und dann haben wir alle gesagt, Stefan, du bist echt der coolste Typ. Das war echt mega lustig. Aber ansonsten passiert nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Immer wenn man die U-Bahn fährt, ist es ziemlich nervig, wenn man sich irgendwie versucht, irgendwo anzulehnen. Aber dann steht da schon jemand, das ist nervig. Ansonsten... Wann war die erste Folge? War die vor oder nach Trump? Vor, ne? Vor Trump, ja. Ich meine, gut, was will man noch dazu sagen, aber eigentlich schon immer noch lustig, also immer noch ein Thema. Dafür haben wir Trump, wie lange ist Trump jetzt schon? Weiß ich nicht. Ne, haben wir nicht drüber gesprochen. Danach war die Folge, die Du weißt schon Folge, die wir löschen mussten, die im Giftschrank ist, und danach haben wir die aufgenommen, zweimal. Und jetzt sind wir wieder da. Aber ich finde es immer noch lustig, dass der, ich will auch nicht über Trump reden, aber eigentlich schon, weil er hat ja gesagt, erst hat er den Klimawandel geleugnet und jetzt hat er gesagt, er will einiges dagegen unternehmen. Und ich finde es, ich glaube, dass es ein Typ ist, der hat einfach irgendwer gesagt, hör mal,
Donald, das ist eigentlich so und so.
Und dann sagt er von sich aus,
ja, eigentlich hast du
Recht. Oder? So einer ist das doch.
Ja, kann sein. Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, der hat einfach
nur erfahren, dass es wesentlich mehr Geld kostet,
all das rückgängig zu machen von Obama und so
und all diese ganzen Bemühungen wieder umkehrend zu machen
und am Ende so viel Geld dafür draufgeht, dass er all seine Versprechen nicht umsetzen kann und das deswegen nicht macht. Also, ihr kennt uns nicht anders, wir sind ein Naturwissenschaftspodcast, ihr kennt es von uns nicht anders, dass wir die naturwissenschaftlichen Fragen der Welt Stück für Stück sezieren und da ist natürlich die Frage, wie funktioniert eigentlich der Treibhauseffekt und warum wird die Erde immer wärmer? Jetzt präsentiert von Florentinbild anschaulich. Also, Kondensation. Dinge verdampfen, steigen in gasförmiger Form wieder auf und kondensieren irgendwo. Das Problem ist, die Ozonschicht ist so dick, dass alles daran konserviert und eine Eisschicht sich bildet, wodurch die ganze Wärme in der Erde gefolgt. Nein, wodurch eine grosse Eiskuppel um die ganze Erde entsteht. Da frieren auch manchmal Satelliten und so ein. Das ist ein riesiges Problem. Und dann tropft das Wasser wieder runter, es regnet ganz viel, und dadurch, dass so viel regnet, werden die Ozeane immer höher, steigen immer höher, und dann überschwemmen die Holland. Ganz kurz mal Storys aus meinem WG-Leben. Es ist echt abgefahren, ich hab, du bist ja in so einer Studenten-WG, da siehst du ja oft auch, man ist ja oft so in seinem eigenen Leben verstrickt, ne, so was sind meine eigenen Träume, was sind meine Ziele, wo will ich hin, wo komme ich her, man übersieht dabei aber auch, dass natürlich andere Menschen genauso ihren Lebensweg gehen und so geschehen zum Beispiel bei einem Nachbarn von mir in der WG, wo ich erst mitbekommen habe, okay, da spielt jemand Querflöte, ja?
Tonleitern. Stundenlang, konstant, also nicht mal der Hauch eines Liedes, einer Melodei, überhaupt nicht. Konstant, irgendwann später, Wochen später, gesellte sich ein Bassspieler dazu, erinnert immer so dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dumm dum Erlebnis teilen kann. Mittlerweile ist noch ein Trompeter war auch mal da und ein Sänger
haben sie und jetzt haben sie zwei Sänger mittlerweile.
Mittlerweile ist eine ganze Band da oben.
Was machen die Sänger denn?
Mittlerweile spielen sie auch wirklich
Musik, aber du kennst ja so diese
Montagen
in so Filmen, wo sie mit dem, ich will Musiker
werden und dann sieht man, er kauft sich das Instrument,
er fängt an zu trainieren,
dann schafft er es nicht so richtig, sein erster Auftritt, er wird Dritter, dann trainiert er weiter bis in die Nacht irgendwie, man sieht so die Nacht Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Instrument, er fängt an zu trainieren, dann schafft er es nicht so richtig, sein erster Auftritt, er wird Dritter, dann trainiert er weiter bis in die Nacht irgendwie, man sieht so die Nacht die Sonne hoch und runter geht und er trainiert und trainiert und irgendwann schafft er es. Aber während der gesamten Montage, der Typ hat auch Nachbarn. Was man in den Filmen nicht mitbekommt, ist, wie geht es dem Nachbarn mit dieser ganzen Trainingsmontein. Das dachte ich mir bei Whiplash, weil er spielt ja in New York oder so und da hat man ja enge Wohnungen und auch kleine Wohnungen. Nee, aber er spielt ja nur in seiner Schule. Nee, aber er hat auch so eine Privatwohnung, wo er auch sitzt und am Schlagzeug standen. Nee, der ist irgendwann in seiner Wohnung und nimmt dann sein Bett irgendwann mit in die Schule. Ja, das kann sein. Und schläft dann in der Schule, um da mehr trainieren zu können. Aber auch bei diesen ganzen Montagen, du denkst nicht an den Typen nebenan. Und der war ich, der am Anfang nur mitbekommen hat und irgendwann mehr Leute und irgendwann ist es wirklich so, dass eine ganze Big Band in meinem Haus spielt, ein Orchester und irgendwie da und die wandern die Treppe hoch und runter und das ist alles so What the Fuck, Leute? Marching Band. Das ist wie so eine Abhängigkeit, es wird langsam immer mehr und irgendwann denkst du dir, oh, ich komme nicht mehr raus. Ja, das ist aber auch bei mir so gewesen. Da war so ein Klavierspieler, der immer ein Lied die ganze Zeit, das fing ja auch mit Tonleitern an. Und das ist wirklich sehr frustrierend. Und man will auch manchmal so Collagen in Filmen sehen und danach will man so ein Flashback auf die ganzen Leute, die die Collage wahnsinnig gemacht hat. Wie viele Leute eigentlich an dieser Collage gestorben sind oder zumindest das Gehör verloren haben.
Das will man nicht mehr ganz gerne sehen.
Bei mir ist es bei den Nachbarn auch strange.
Ich habe diese Woche in meiner Heimat meinen Schlüssel vergessen,
alle Schlüssel, und habe aber Ersatzschlüssel im Keller.
Aber nicht von meiner Haustür, sondern nur von der Wohnungstür habe ich den Schlüssel.
Das heißt, ich muss immer klingeln bei irgendwem, der mich dann reinlässt unten,
um dann quasi in meine Wohnung zu können, weil ich nur meinen Wohnungsschlüssel habe. Und dann hat niemand aufgemacht, dann habe ich irgendwo bei irgendwem, der mich dann reinlässt unten, um dann quasi in meine Wohnung zu können, weil ich nur meinen Wohnungsschlüssel habe.
Und dann habe ich, dann hat jemand aufgemacht, dann habe ich irgendwo bei jemandem, der ganz oben wohnt, geklingelt, der hat mir dann aufgemacht und dann dachte ich mir, ja, soll ich jetzt ganz hochgehen und sagen, danke fürs Aufmachen, dann wieder ganz runter gehen in meine Wohnung rein oder gehe ich einfach meine Wohnung rein? Wenn ich faul wie ich bin, gehe natürlich sofort in meine Wohnung und höre dann nur von unten, wie jemand wahnsinnig unterschreibt,
Hallo, wer ist da, der jemand wahnsinnig unterschreibt,
Hallo, wer ist da?
Der komplett wahnsinnig wurde, weil er dachte, da ist irgendein Einbrecher,
weil er die Tür quasi gehört, wie die aufgegangen ist.
Und dann hat sie ja nichts gerührt so.
Und da habe ich dann vielleicht so einen, weiss ich nicht,
einen Polizeiruf ausgelöst.
Ja.
Schon möglich, gut möglich.
Man weiss nicht, wie man dann reagieren soll, aber ich bin nicht hochgegangen. Nicht so schlecht, aber auch nicht so lustig. So mittendrin. So mittendrin. Aber du lernst kein Instrument mehr, ne? Hast du nicht mal eine Klavierphase gehabt? Ich hab mir jetzt überlegt, mir ein Klavier zu kaufen, aber es ist immer so ein Hin und her, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, weil ich denk mir immer so, ich will's jetzt haben, aber sobald ich es habe, will ich es nicht mehr und dann steht es nur rum. Und ich bin auch ein Purist tatsächlich. Also es klingt komisch, aber es war auch zum Beispiel so, ich wollte immer einen Bogen haben als Kind, Pfeil und Bogen und habe mir mal Bögen gebaut aus Holz, habe ich dann gehobelt und eine Eibe. Gehübelt. Eines der besten Bogenhölzer ist Eibe und es gab in der ganzen Stadt nur eine Eibe und da bin ich dann irgendwann mal in der Nacht eingebrochen und habe diese Eibe abgesäbelt. Das ist auch ein geiler Geschichtenplot eigentlich. Nur eine Eibe, aber die steht unter Naturschutz und ist mitten auf so einem heiligen Platz. Und jede Nacht läufst du da vorbei und irgendwann siehst du die Strumpfmaske über. Ja, vor allem Eibe sind so total verkrüppelt gewachsen. Die sind überhaupt nicht gerade. Und trotzdem eignet sich deren Holz am besten für Bögen. Das heißt, du brauchst eine Eibe, aber auch eine, die möglichst gerade ist.
Und dann musst du dir halt so zuhobeln und es ist alles mega aufwendig.
Und da ist aber ein guter Bogen draus geworden, der leider irgendwann kaputt gegangen ist.
Und irgendwann habe ich mir dann einen Bogen gekauft.
Weil sich rausgläht, dass das Eibe doch nicht so geil ist als Holz.
Ja, und irgendwann habe ich mir dann einen Bogen zu Weihnachten gekriegt,
dann durfte ich mir einen Bogen aussuchen.
Und dann habe ich da in diesem Bogenladen verschiedene Bögen ausprobiert.
Und dann habe ich den gekauft. Und nachdem ich ihn gekauft habe, ist mir aufgefallen, weil der war so mit Leder umwickelt, dass der gar nicht aus Holz war, sondern aus Beefy, nee, sondern aus Fiberglas. Das sind die neuen Gags. Daran könnt ihr euch gewöhnen. Erinnert euch die alten Folgen vielleicht noch mal. Ein bisschen demütig. Rollt noch mal mit den Augen nach oben und denkt an die schönen Folgen, die wir damals hatten. Das ist jetzt vorbei. Wir machen jetzt solche Gags. Wir machen auch keine Gags mehr. Wir erzählen einfach nur Geschichten von früher. Und der war nicht aus Holz, sondern aus Fieberglas. Und irgendwie habe ich den dann weniger gemocht. Weil das war nicht so ein echter Bogen, wie ein Legolas benutzen würde. Ich hätte auch einen Fieberglasbogen. Und sowas ist beim Klavier auch so ein bisschen, dass ich das Gefühl habe, wenn es nur so ein Elektropiano ist, ist es nicht so das Echte, sondern will ich nicht.
Und dann, ich brauche mal ein Elektropiano, weil das andere wäre zu laut.
Ja, aber, ja, wir sind halt, man will halt immer das, was man gerade nicht hat, und man will, was man hat, nicht mehr unbedingt haben.
Das ist doch normal. Gibt es da irgendwie ein Fachwort für eigentlich? Nee. Dummheit? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ja, irgendwie sowas. Es ist wirklich dieses Ding, das verstehe ich auch nicht, wie es funktioniert. Wir haben hier so ein Föhn, Föhnartiges Gerät, was die Luft warm macht. Was ist da genau drin, dass es warm wird sofort? Weil das zieht ja nur Luft an von hinten. Habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Verstehst du, wie ein Toaster funktioniert?
Ja, da sind diese Drähte drin, die total warm werden.
Ja, Moment mal. Die Idee von der Glühbirne ist doch, dass in der Birne, dass da irgendwie so Vakuum drin ist oder irgendein besonderes Gas, dass der Draht nicht verglüht.
Der Wolfram-Draht.
Dass der nicht verglüht.
Ja.
So, aber warum verglüht denn der Draht im Toaster nicht?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach eine andere Art von Metall. Draht. Aber warum nimmt man nicht den Toasterdraht für Glühbirnen? Du kannst ja auch einen Toaster an die Wand hängen. Ich glaube, weil das billiger ist auf Dauer oder weil er heller ist oder keine Ahnung. Der Toasterdraht ist ja auch kein, das glüht ja auch nicht so, dass du denkst, wow, der scheint ja nicht, wie ein heiliges Toast, was da plötzlich. Das scheint ja nicht von unten so ein Lichtstrahl, das ist einfach nur ein grelles scheiss Orange. Schade eigentlich, es wäre eigentlich ganz gut, wenn so ein Toaster noch so ein, ein Toaster, der leuchtet, wenn er fertig ist? Ich finde ja, ähm, ich finde es total clever, als ich irgendwann mal gesehen habe, dass Fussballvereine, die haben ja immer Merchandise durchgespielt und die haben auch Toaster bringen die raus, die das Vereinswappen reinbrennen. Aber jedes Toast ist dann per Definition verbrannt. Ja, oder hat es nicht gleichmässig getoastert. Es ist einfach ein schlechter Toaster, der das Gimmick hat des Vereinswappens, was auch echt ein bisschen bescheuert ist. Aber sind dann die Toaster total begehrt, die ein grosses Wappen haben, damit der Toast möglichst gut durch ist und irgendwie so ein Verein wie, keine Ahnung, Werner Dortmund oder sowas, wo dann die so ein ganz kleines Logo haben. Ich glaube, dass Vereinslogos sich, also dass sie sich nicht in der Größe unterscheiden, sondern mehr durch die Form, aber, ja, aber das ist eine spannende Frage. Naja, es gibt ja auch Länder mit kleinen Flaggen und Länder mit grossen Flaggen. Ja. Wenn du sagst, das ist mein Land, hat eine 200 mal 400 Meter Flagge, dann müssen die anderen sagen, ja okay. Und Wikipedia denkt, shit. Fuck, dafür sind unsere Server nicht ausgelegt. Aber es ist ja wirklich so, Deutschland hat ja auch nicht, also man sagt ja schwarz-rot-gold, aber laut Flaggen-Code ist es ja schwarz-rot-gelb, weil Gold nicht erlaubt ist. Aber wer hat diese Regeln aufgestellt? Wer hat gesagt, Gold hat es nicht erlaubt? Ein verdammter Gold-Hasser. Jemand, der Gold hasst. Aber ich meine, das kriegst du doch nicht durch. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, hey, pass mal auf, ich reguliere jetzt die Flaggen. Und alle so, okay. Warum sollten die Leute auf dich hören? Du kannst als Flagge nehmen, was du willst. Und warum ist schwarz erlaubt? Und weiss. Weiss ist keine Farbe. Warum sagen Leute weiss, oder war schwarz? Weiss ist nicht keine Farbe. Ach, weiss ich auch. Das ist genau so ein Scheiß wie Daumen ist kein Finger oder so. Oder irgendein Crap. Oder Augenbrauen sind keine Haare. Ihr kennt die ganzen Sachen. Dieses Erdbeeren sind keine Beeren, sondern Nüsse. Das ist das Letzte. Ja, wen interessiert's? Ja, vor allem stimmt auch einfach nicht. Ja, es ist einfach falsch. Die Wissenschaft hat sich nach meiner Meinung zu... Übrigens, es gibt ein großes Update zu den Triceratöpsen. Die hatten jetzt wohl nicht nur Federn und die Stacheln waren noch biegsam und so einen Scheiss, die waren aus Plüsch, nein, es gibt jetzt noch neue wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse, die hatten so aufpustbare Backen, die hatten so eklige Blasenbacken. Ach was, und die haben wie Kängurus durch die Gegend gesprungen und jedes Mal Boing gemacht, wenn sie gesprungen sind. Ja, genau, Hui, haben sie gesagt. Keinlich wahr sein. Ja, aber ohne Scheisse denke ich mir auch Wissenschaft, hört einfach auf, guckt in die Zukunft, verhofft in die Frage reinzugucken. Ja, weiß ich nicht, fragwürdige Message. Aber bei mir geht es manchmal so, wenn ich Bücher lese, gibt es manchmal so verschiedene Formulierungen, die ich nicht ganz, die ich halt schon verstehe, aber in meinem Kopf anders wahrnehme, als die eigentlich zu verstehen sind. Zum Beispiel dicke Backen machen. Da stelle ich mir immer vor, wie jemand die Backen so aufpustet. Das meint man ja aber nicht damit, oder? Doch, glaub schon. Dicke Backen machen. Ja. Oder die Lippenspitzen. Ja. Das sind so ganz, ich habe immer so ganz übertriebene Karikaturen in meinem Kopf. Das ist ja so eine Sprache, die nur in Büchern existiert. Ja, eben. Weil die ist allein aus der Not heraus entstanden, Dinge zu beschreiben, die man normalerweise nicht beschreiben muss. Ich habe letztens ein Drehbuch geschrieben, also mein Gott, ein Text für einen lustigen Sketch-Themel gedreht. Und da sollte diese Geste so, dass man sich so nach getaner Arbeit so die Hände sauer macht, so dieses so.
Aber das ist schwer zu beschreiben.
Ja, es gibt eben auch Diskussionen, wenn dieses mit dem Daumen verächtigt zur Seite gucken und die Augen so verdrehen.
Wie soll man das im Drehbuch schreiben, dass es cool klingt?
Aber du würdest schreiben so, this guy, mach die this guy Geste oder mach die Arbeit geschafft Geste oder sowas, aber es hat keine wirklichen Beschreibung der Geste oder sowas. Ja, und Lippenspitzen, also immer wenn das irgendein Autor schreibt, dann lese ich da irgendwie so ein fucking Stephen King Buch und es soll gruselig sein, und dann steht da, Jack hat die Lippen gespitzt, da denke ich mir immer, da muss ich halt immer automatisch so ein bisschen losprusten, weil ich mir denke, der Kugel war bestimmt gerade lustig, weil ich stelle mir das mal so übertrieben noch vor, also spitze Lippen oder dicke Backen. Das stimmt schon, weil man sich ja immer fragt, warum betont der Autor das gerade, er könnte ja auch die Fußstellung betonen oder wie er gerade die Arme hält oder so, warum betont er das gerade, es gibt ja immer Millionen Dinge, die er nicht betont. Ja, genau. Es ist auch mega interessant, wann ein Autor entscheidet, die Surroundings nicht mehr zu beschreiben, nicht mehr zu sagen, die Landschaft zu beschreiben oder so und sich den Figuren widmet oder den Handlungen, sondern theoretisch kannst du diesen Raum ja auch über 800 Seiten beschreiben, in denen wir gerade sind. Ja, wie würdest du ihn beschreiben? Ich würde ihn als kleine Abstellkammer am Rande eines Gebäudes beschreiben, der zu kalt ist, um darin zu arbeiten, aber gross genug und warm genug, um darin einen Podcast aufzunehmen. Am Rand steht ein Schrank, vollgepackt bis oben hin, mit Requisiten, die für Drehs gebraucht wurden und die jetzt niemand mehr ansieht. Traurig stehen sie nebeneinander und warten, bis sie für einen nächsten Dreh benötigt werden könnten. Requisiten haben ein trauriges Leben eigentlich. Da wird immer wahnsinnig viel Arbeit reingesteckt für einen Moment und dann ist alles wieder weg. Mega und dann ist es egal. Das ist so mega wichtig, mega schön, teuer und dann egal. Brauchst du es nie wieder. Außer du scheidest. Scheidet man sich eigentlich auch ein Brautkleid? Oder? Keine gleiche Frage. Ist es eine Scheidungszeremonie, dass man sagt, na ich meine, es ist ja eigentlich, also kirchlich gibt es ja nicht Scheidung, aber das ist wie so ein Vertrag unterschreiben, so dann. Ja, ich glaube, ich weiß es nicht genau. Oder trifft man sich dann nochmal mit den Eltern und sagt so, ach ja, jetzt ist noch ein kaltes Buffet, irgendwie die Mutter stochert so ein bisschen verlegen im Kuchen rum oder sowas, kann doch auch nicht sein. Wird man danach beglückwünscht, weil es ja eigentlich was Positives. Ja. So, oder, oder, ich habe mir immer vorgestellt, dass es so ein Mann mit einer Brille, die so tief sitzt, der ihn so verachtungsvoll anguckt und dann einfach den Vertrag, den man unterstrieben hat,
beim Standesamt einfach durchreißt.
Und dann geben sie mir die Ringe und dann holt er so einen grossen
Hammer raus und fleckt auf die
Ringe an. Oder so diesen Amboss, wo
das drauf schmilzt, wo das in so
einen grossen Ofen steht. Und da wird dann so ein Schwert draus gespielt.
Ich nehme mich nur vor, dass er sich anguckt, über die Brille weg
anguckt, das durchreißt,
achtzehn Mal und dann so die Riesel
auf dich abrieseln lässt. Und dann kommt noch ein Fotograf, ein Scheidungsfotograf und dann ist es vorbei. Raus. Raus. Raus. Was ist der beste Job der Welt? Bienen, Domter. Imker. Nee, Imker ist, glaube ich. Imker ist der mit oben. Imker ist definitiv der beste Job. Letztens, manchmal, wir drehen ja so manchmal auf Locations und das sind ja manchmal fremde Wohnungen einfach von Menschen, die nicht wir sind. Und dann hat man immer so einen kleinen Einblick. Danke, dass das Wort fremd beschrieben hat. So einen kleinen Einblick in anderen Alltag. Und was mir zum Beispiel auffällt, ist, dass die meisten fremden Wohnungen exakt gleich aussehen. Zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, ob das auffällt, aber es gibt von True F Fruits diese Smoothies und da gibt es auch diese grossen Flaschen, so ich glaube ein Liter oder so und wirklich in jeder zweiten Wohnung werden diese Smoothie True Fruits Flaschen verwendet, um irgendwie so Müsli und so Sesam und sowas zu verwenden, aber genau die, das ist so ganz merkwürdig. Weil die schön sind. Aber warum gerade die? Weil die ist die einzig schönen, weiß ich nicht. Aber immer die. Haben die mal damit geworben, dass man das machen kann? Oder konnte man mal so Samen darin kaufen? Oder Mohn oder so ein Kram? Und nun der neue Song von Christopher. Ganz merkwürdig. Und da hing zum Beispiel auch ein Kalender in dieser Wohnung. Und ich meine, Kalender ist ja, ich glaube, nichts drückt deinen Charakter so sehr aus wie Kalender. Hast du den Hot Girls, den Hot Boys, die Rennwagen, irgendwie den Carb-Rater oder so was? Wer hat heutzutage noch fucking Kalender? Das macht keinen Sinn. Ja, vor allem, also als Kind hatte ich manchmal Kalender oder meine Eltern hatten Kalender und ich habe mir den Kalender angeguckt und habe mir natürlich alle Seiten angeguckt und dann gesagt, nee, kenne ich ja schon. Aber ganz kurz, was mein Leben gut beschreibt ist, ich habe neulich so eine Schublade gefunden, wo alte Notizhefte oder so Jahresplaner drin waren. Und ich finde, das beschreibt mein Leben sehr gut, dass die ersten drei Januartage beschrieben waren, vielleicht noch einer im Februar, wo ein Termin schon länger feststand und danach leer, einfach nichts weiter. Das ist genau mein Leben. Ich fange sehr viele Dinge an, aber die wenigsten halte ich durch.
Ja, aber es sind auch so Tagebücher, auch so Tagebücher, immer weniger und dann irgendwann gar nicht mehr und dann, man merkt, die Schrift hat sich massiv verändert, so so von 2001, nächster Eintrag 2014, übrigens mit einer ganz schludringen Schrift, irgendwie so, ja, ich habe jetzt so ganz verächtlich geschrieben.
Tagebuch, ey. Hast du Tagebuch geschrieben, richtig? Ja, ja. Richtig lange auch? Ja, ich überlege mir immer, wie lange es noch dauert, bis ich aus dem so vorlesen kann, so wie jetzt das Traumtagebuch oder so, weil da stehen schon noch kritische Sachen drin teilweise. Ja, ja, ich glaube auch. Aber teilweise auch, als ich eingeschult wurde ins Gymnasium, weiß ich noch, wo ich geschrieben habe, wo ich einfach beschrieben habe, was ich mir an dem Tag gemacht habe. So habe ich gesagt, so ja, da gab es von unserem Hausaufgabenheft, dieses H-E-F-F-T, ich weiß nicht, ob man das kennt. Nein. Hausaufgabenheft, und da gab es so ein Gewinnspiel, da musste man seine Adresse hinschreiben, dann hat man so Sticker bekommen mit diesem Heftlogo, und dann musste man die Sticker irgendwo hinkleben und dann ein Foto davon machen und das da hinschicken und dann konnte man was gewinnen. Und dann habe ich so ganz schnippisch hingeschrieben, ja, ich habe da bei dem Gewinnspiel mitgemacht, aber eigentlich will ich gar nicht bei dem Gewinnspiel mitmachen, ich will nur die Sticker haben. Und dann so ein Zwinker-Smiley da so, wo ich war dann so, wow, Rebel in the House! Badass! Das vertraue ich nur meinem Tagebuch an. Ich will gar nicht bei dem Gewinnspiel. Das ist der Level an krimineller Energie, den ich aufgewendet habe in meiner Pubertät. Ich will diese Sticker haben. Und ich will eigentlich gar nicht am Gewinnspiel teilnehmen. Das war wirklich der maximale Level. Aber ganz kurz, um den Kalender zurückzukommen. Der Kalender sagt ja viel über einen Menschen aus. Da hast du den Star Wars Kalender, den Lego Star Wars Kalender, den Indiana Jones Lego Star Wars Kalender. Den Adventskalender. Den Playmobil Kalender oder der Kalender, die die Person hatte, die diese Wohnung gehört hat, die hatte den Bienen, Honig und Wachsprodukte Vermarktungskalender.achsprodukte-Kalender? Kein Bienenkalender, kein Honigkalender, sondern ein Kalender zum Honigvertrieb. Ja, also nicht kein Bienenliebhaber, sondern jemand, dessen grosse Leidenschaft der Bienenprodukte-Vertrieb ist. Und da war dann wirklich irgendwie im Oktober, glaube ich, haben wir da gedreht, und da war dann gerade das Bild, war so ein Typ, der an so einem Messestand stand, mit so ganz vielen Wachs, also Kerzen und so Honig in der Hand und dann hat er geschrieben, der Oktober ist der perfekte Monat, um Kerzen und Honig zu vertreiben und sich auf das Ambrodius-Fest zu freuen. Dann stand da Ambrodius-Fest, was anscheinend der Heiliger des Honigs ist.
Dieser gesamte Kalender geht nur um Honigvertrieb.
Aber auch geil, dass dieser Vertrieb-Kalender
auch nicht mit der echten Welt kompatibel ist,
weil das Ambrodius-Fest interessiert
einen Scheiss in der echten Welt.
Weihnachten ganz klein nur draufgeschrieben.
Dann habe ich mal wirklich so ein bisschen durchgeblättert
und da standen wirklich so wichtige Tage
drin, wie Vorstadsversammlung des Honigvereins Mecklenburg-Vorpommern stand da drin. So weißt du, weil dann wirklich auch so politische Themen, wo man sich darauf vorbereitet. Also ganz merkwürdig, also wirklich so eine extrem, was ist die kleinste Zielgruppe? Ich finde lustig, wenn so ein Kalender, den man aber verpackt vorher, das heißt, man sieht nur das erste Bild, um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, so Januar, da ist eine glückliche Familie drauf, dann kauft man sich das oder so und dann heckt man sich das auf und dann Februar und dann ist die Familie schon nicht mehr so ganz so glücklich, dann drittes Tag, ein Kind fehlt vielleicht oder so und dann schon April und man merkt, die Frau hat ein blaues Auge, irgendwas ist da los, gerade ist irgendwas im Butsch und dann ist man im Mai und dann denkt man, ach Gott, und dann im Dezember weiß man nicht, ob da noch eine Familie ist. Eine andere, eine ganz andere Familie. Ein anderer Vater oder so. Ja, finde ich auch gut, aber kleiner Fehler, auf Kalendern ist ja hinten drauf, sind ja alle zwölf Bilder abgedruckt. Und das ist wie, als ob bei einem Adventskalender hinten drauf schon drinsteht, was in welchem Türchen zu finden ist. Das ist bescheuert. Ja, aber da musst du dir jetzt auch mal ehrlich gegenübertreten, Stefan Tiesel, ob du nicht, wenn du einen Kalender kaufst, darauf verzichten möchtest, alle Bilder gesehen zu haben. Ob du dir den Sexy Bunny 2012 Kalender für 1,99 Euro in der Tanke kaufen würdest, wenn du wüsstest, was da für heiße Picks noch abgebildet sind den Rest des Jahres. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich brauche nämlich auch nicht. Ich glaube, da lugt man dann noch da ganz gerne drauf.
Was ist die kleinste Zielgruppe der Welt, die noch vermarktet wird oder die noch beliefert wird mit Konto? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich finde, so Vertriebszeug, also so Firmeninterne, Journal, das finde ich auch sehr interessant. Ja, das stimmt. So, da gibt's, da hat, das hat, meine Mutter hat lange für ihre, also die Abteilung meiner Mutter hat lange für ihre Firma, ungefähr 300 Mitarbeiter, haben die so ein Journal rausgebracht.
Und dann konnte man auch Karten gewinnen für Borussia Dortmund.
Und dafür musste man ein Sudoku machen.
Und meine Mutter hat dann das Rätsel auch in Auftrag gegeben.
Ein Sudoku musste dann gemacht werden.
Das wird ja dafür extra gemacht.
Wer denkt sich das aus?
Und wie macht man an Sudoku musste dann gemacht werden. Das wird ja dafür extra gemacht. Wer denkt sich das aus? Und wie macht man das rückwärts? Schreibt man erst alle Zahlen rein? Und radiert dann einfach random Sachen. Ja, aber dann musste ja auch sicher gehen, dass das lösbar ist. Ja, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es da Programme gibt, die das einfach generieren. Aber ich habe ja auch mal beim Callcenter gearbeitet, und die haben auch mit Zeitungen zusammengearbeitet und haben da auch so Gewinnspiele gemacht. Und da war es dann immer so, dass irgendwie um ein Uhr nachts oder so, wo ich nur noch Telefondienst hatte, kam dann der Grafiker zu mir und hatte dann so zwei Bilder. Warum nur noch Telefondienst bei einem Callcenter? Nee, weil ja dann andere Leute gearbeitet haben und so und der Chef war da und die haben so Briefe verschickt. Ich fand das Wort nur Telefondienst, das war lustig, bez Hotlines. Nee, ich musste da schon noch vor diesen Schienesachen machen. Auf jeden Fall kam dann der Grafiker zu mir und hat mir so ein Bild gegeben, mit zweimal demselben Bild, und einmal waren halt zehn Fehler drin, dieses klassische Vergleichsbild. So, und dann hat er gesagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das zu schwierig ist. Schau mal, ob du alle zehn Fehler findest. Und ich glaube, ich war in meinem Leben noch nie so angespannt und voller Ehrgeiz wie in dem Moment. Weil er schon meinte so, ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht ein bisschen zu schwierig ist, schau mal, ob du es lösen kannst. Und ich war wirklich am Limit, wirklich am Limit meiner Kapazitäten. Und ich hatte davor zwei Stunden lang nur, ich hatte so ein Baguette neben mir liegen, ein Stück Butter und Salamischeiben. Und ich habe immer ein Stück Brot, Butter drauf, Salami, Essen. Und am Ende war nur das Stück Butter weg. Ja, und am Ende Brot, Butter, Salami, Mund. Brot, Butter, Salami, Mund. Das zwei Stunden lang, konstant ohne Pause. Das war so ein Riesenbaguette, was mit so einer Feder immer näher zu dir geschoben wurde. Weil so durch den Raum ging, so zehn Meter lang, immer langer wurde zu dir. Und das machst du zwei Stunden lang. Du liegst da einfach nur noch halb auf dem Boden, deine Arterien haben schon lange aufgegeben vor einer halben Stunde, und dann kommt der Typ rein und du, kurz vor der Erblindung, musst dann die Bilder finden, ich glaube, ich habe zwei, ich glaube, ich habe wirklich zehn Minuten gebraucht, habe zwei Fehler gefunden und meinte dann, mir passt, alles klar, das ist genau der Level, den ich erwarte. Und niemand hat den Gutschein gewonnen für die Therme in der Nähe. Ich habe mal im Labor gearbeitet in meiner Schulzeit, so nebenbei, als Nebenjob. Und da stand meine Aufgabe darin, dass ich gucken muss, ob die Verpackung Auswirkungen hat auf das Produkt. Da musste ich zum Beispiel Sonnencremes testen mit so einer blauen Verpackung und musste dann gucken, ob die blau wird zum Beispiel. Und dann stehen halt so ganz viel, als mit so einem grossen Kühlraum, wo die dann so stehen und dann kriegst du so einen Zettel und musst dir dann halt einen nehmen, den du zugeteilt bekommst, der steht dann schon ein Jahr da drin und dann musst du, dann hast du so einen grossen Bottich und dann pumpst du die ganze Zeit der Sonnencreme daraus und machst das in den Bottich zwanzig Mal und musst dann das Produkt beschreiben. Und dann hast du so einen Fragebogen, ist das Produkt die richtige Konsistenz, hat das eine Farbe verändert und so weiter. Und dann musst du die ganze Zeit, aber das ist der Sonnencreme, also wird deine Hand unfassbar fettig ganz schnell, du hast aber doch diesen Zettel in der Hand und es wird alles wahnsinnig verwischtend die ganze Zeit. Aber du hast so einen coolen Laborkittel an, was eigentlich geil ist. Du denkst, ja, ich bin schon Wissenschaftler. Ja, man denkt so, Leute, die am Parkplatz sind, denken so, wow, der heilt gerade AIDS oder so. Aber eigentlich guckt er nur, ob die Sonnencreme blau wird. Aber er pumpt da die ganze Zeit drin. Das war eigentlich ein cooler Job. Und seitdem haben deine Hände nie wieder Sonnenbrand bekommen. Nie wieder? Wie so Obelix, der in den Zaubertrank gefallen ist. Deine Hände einfach nie wieder. Einfach dauergeschützt, konstant.
Ja, wie so Achilles. So eine Stelle ist massiv gefährdet,
die ist massiv weiss und ganz schnell ganz rot, aber so ganz eng gefasst,
so ganz enge Kante.
Ja, ich habe also in den zwei Malen, als ich gesonnen badet hatte,
hatte ich immer Angst, dass es total bescheuert danach aussieht, weil immer nur ein Teil des Körpers gebräunt wird.
Das heißt, du kannst deinen Körper ja gar nicht so positionieren,
dass letztlich alle Teile gebräunt werden. Aber du warst doch auch sehr dick. Du warst eine fette Boje. Und deswegen frage ich mich, dann hängt ja auch Fett manchmal über etwas, über andere Haut. Über Fett, ja. Und dieser Überhang verhindert ja, dass darunter was braun wird. Genau, deswegen musst du die Falten auch falten. Das heißt, du musst dann auch mal wirklich wenden. Du musst auch manchmal wirklich wenden und
auch mal kopfüberhängen so ein bisschen, also
dich umgedreht auf eine Liege setzen, damit das
Fett in die andere Richtung rüber schwabbelt.
Also das ist klassisch, du stellst so eine Uhr, so eine Eieruhr,
30 Minuten, nach 30 Minuten musst du einmal deinen Bauch
so komplett von unten nach
wenden! Einmal wälzen und dann
von unten nach oben wälzen, du legst dir
dann dein Fett so über den Bauch rüber. Ja klar,
dann hast du so Wäscherkklammern und dann machst du dich
an deinen Schultern fest zum Beispiel.
Und da findest du eine Menge in diesen Falten.
Also Kleingeld und sowas?
Klar, Kleingeld, Fussel, Pokémon-Karten,
alte, Yu-Gi-Oh-Karten, findest du eine Menge.
Letztens wurde eine Yu-Gi-Oh-Karte für 11.000
Euro verkauft.
Es gibt hier in Köln so einen
Yu-Gi-Oh-Laden, wo man, wo die, jeden
Donnerstag spielen die Yu-Gi-Oh. Also richtig professionell und so. Ich würde das so gerne mal erleben, weil ich will das Klientel, das finde ich so interessant. Aber haben die dann auch so diese Arm-Dinger, diese kleinen Tische an den Armen? Ja, wahrscheinlich stehen die auch in so einer großen Arena und da kämpfen riesige Hologrammonster gegeneinander. Naja, aber die aus Plastik gibt es ja. Da gab es bei euch ja nicht den Deppen, der mit so einem scheiß Teil am Arm, der einfach wirklich schon, bevor die Schule betreten hat, zusammengeschlagen wurde. Man weiss aber auch nie, ist das gerade cool, das zu haben oder nicht? Nein. Und dann läufst du in der Schule mit diesem Ding und dann siehst du, niemand hat es, niemand anderes ist auf diesen Trend reingefallen und dann machst du es so, so niedergeschlagen machst du es wieder in deinen Tonnister rein und dann gehst du wieder in die Schule. Tonnister. Tonne, haben wir immer gesagt. Tonny. Tonni hatte nicht wirklich gesagt. Ja, manchmal doch. Ich habe im Urlaub diesen Jahres, weiß nicht, ob ich schon erzählt habe, aber da habe ich massiv Sonnenbrand gehabt. Habe ich schon erzählt. Also es war unfassbar. Also unglaublich. Und dann hat sich auch wirklich so eine Kante gebildet, so eine ganz scharfe Kante aus massiv braun danach und massiv weiss. Das war so erstaunlich. Das sieht dann aus wie so ein Sandwich-Eis, so mit rot, weiss, braun und Eis. Mega, ich sah aus mit Deutschlandflagge. Ja. Nee, hat nicht so gut gepasst. Ich sah aus wie Wie heissen diese Sandwich? Die haben doch immer so einen Fürst, Fürst irgendwas, aber welcher Fürst der Welt hat dieses scheiß Sandwich erfunden? Fürst Pückler, Fürst, Fürst. Pückler Fürst. Ich dachte immer Fürst, der Erste. Hey, Moment, aber hat dann ein Fürst aus dem 14. Jahrhundert gesagt, so, boah, sobald es mal Eis gibt, weißt du, was geil wäre? Vanille, Schokolade und Erdbeer, inzwischen zwei Waffeln, also... Aber er war voll seiner Zeit, weil er gedacht hat, wir wissen nicht mehr, was Eis ist, du Schwingideon, wir wissen Wir wissen nicht mehr, was Naturgesetz ist. Es ist mir schon klar, dass ich nicht wüsste, was Eis ist, aber wenn es das gibt, dann mach doch mal bitte Vanille, Erdbeer und Schokolade in eine Waffel. Dann mach bitte erstmal Farbstoff rein und Geschmackstoff in Eis. Das sind verschiedene Anordnungen und das zwischen zwei Waffeln. Was sind Waffeln? Keine Ahnung. Und jetzt... Er hängt noch ein paar Juden da. Scheiße drauf. Er hängt noch ein paar fucking Juden. Welche Erfindung war am meisten vor seiner Zeit? Haben Nazis nicht so UFOs gebaut? Wie viel ist an dieser Mond-Nazi-Nummer eigentlich dran? Dass die Nazis den Mond gebaut haben? Ja, dass die Nazis den Mond und an Todesstern. Genau, dass die Nazis den Mond gerichtet haben und jetzt drauf wohnen. Wie viel ist da dran? Hat man auf dem Mond, also blöde Frage jetzt, aber hat man auf dem Mond auch mal gegraben, also mal einfach eine schöne Schaufel, eine schöne Spaten in die Hand genommen und einfach mal ein bisschen Schweiss auf die Stirn getrieben und einfach mal gesagt, wir graben jetzt einfach mal hier ein Stück. Ich habe noch nie einen Astronaut mit einer Schaufel gesehen. Ich habe auch noch nie einen Astronaut mit so einer Hawaii-Kette gesehen. Das sind so ganz viele Fragen, die man noch offen hat. Das ist ja das Erste, wenn du irgendwo ankommst, der gräbst ja erst mal. Nee, das Erste, was du machst, ist immer WLAN-Passwortfragen. Das stimmt. Und das frage ich mich auch. Das wäre das grösste Problem. Ist die ISS, gibtLAN drauf? Ja, bestimmt, ne? Ja, glaub ich schon. Guter Empfang? Edge? Oh, Rim vielleicht eher. Oh! Weiß ich nicht genau. Ich hab nicht ganz verstanden, aber schön so eine Sci-Fi-Referenz. Nee, ich weiss nicht, der Mond ist mir auch ein bisschen suspekt. Aber da hab ich mich auch mal gefragt, angenommen eine andere Welt im Universum, die vielleicht zum ähnlichen Zeitpunkt intelligentes Leben entwickelt haben wie die Erde, die aber keinen Mond haben, glaubst du, dass sie ähnlich schnell ein Interesse für das Universum entwickeln und ähnlich schnell auch checken, dass deren Erde nicht das Zentrum der Welt ist? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, der Mond lehrt einem relativ schnell, Dinge drehen sich, also der Mond ist sehr einfach, weil es ist ein ultranahes Ding, was dir sofort lehrt, was los ist. Und auch, ich glaube, es ist massiv wichtig. Ich glaube schon, vor allem, ich glaube, so ein Zwischenziel ist ja wichtig, weil so ein Raumfahrt ist ja nicht nur jetzt Mensch, der Entdeckergeist, sondern es sind ja auch finanzielle Interessen dahinter und zu sagen, irgendjemand muss sich genug dafür interessieren, um da Geld dafür auszugeben und wenn du jetzt erstmal sagst, okay, wir müssen jetzt erstmal zum Mars, ja, vergesst das einfach, Leute, das klappt nie, wir stecken da erstmal kein Geld rein, ist glaube ich was anderes, als wenn du sagst, Mond ist durchaus machbar, schaffen wir erstmal, ich glaube, es kann durchaus sein, wenn es den Mond nicht gäbe, dass es nie so weit gekommen wäre, ausser man hat auf der Erde halt schon so krasse Technologien entwickelt. Aber das finde ich schon mega interessant. Ich glaube, es hat schon ein paar tausend Jahre einfach geholfen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, ich denke mal, aber auch so eine Erde mit zwei Monden, wo man einfach weiß, okay, wir haben ausgerechnet, in zwölf Jahren dotzen die einfach aneinander. Wir sind tot. Und was dann passiert, weiß man nicht. Eigentlich, es ist hart. Und dann, was macht man dann? Würde man, würde sich da wirklich die ganze Welt zusammentun und sagen, wir bauen irgendwie einen grossen Wattebausch? Ich glaube, dann brechen so Zweige wie Unterhaltung weg komplett. Meinst du? Ja, ich glaube, dann brechen so nebensächliche Dinge total weg und es entwickelt sich so eine total spitze Spezialisierung. Und das ist halt so das Ding, dann arbeiten wir dafür, das ist das Ziel. So wie Krieg, dass dann die gesamte Bevölkerung nur für die Kriegsanstrengung sorgt. Ja, genau. Ja, das ist eben Krieg zu sein, gegen den Tod. Gegen den Mond. Ja, das finde ich schon cool. Ich fände es immer geil, wenn die Menschheit einen Krieg führt gegen irgendwas, das jetzt nicht so menschlich ist. Das ist jetzt nicht so eine Schuld und dann Kriegsverbrechen, sondern einfach mal alle gegen den Mond. So, aber wirklich wie so ein Spiel, wie so ein Sport. Das ist ja auch so, man schiesst ein Tor, so geht es ja um nichts. Einfach mal wir alle gegen den Mond. Mal gucken, wie weit wir kommen. Die Menschheit gegen den Mond. Wenn den Mond weiter schubsen kann, so ein bisschen wegschubsen kann. Ja, wie so Billard. Ja, das finde ich immer cool. Der Saturn hat die Farbe geändert, einfach. Alter. Ich finde das so spannend. Sorry, wenn ich dich da kurz aus deinem humoristischen Vakuum ziehe. Ja. Aber ich finde das so interessant. Welche Farbe ist er jetzt? Der war doch orange eigentlich. Ja, ist er so weisslich, so silbrig, weisslich, gelblich, schmerzlich geworden. Ganz spannende. Ganz interessant, wie so ein Tiger. So gelb-schwarzer. Er hat so eine Maske, so eine Katze, die sich schminken lassen. Aber jetzt verarschen die und so, oder? Das kann ja nicht wahr sein. Was ist das denn für eine Seite? Der Postillon. Das würde ich aber als Aliens machen. Wenn ich das alles kontrollieren könnte, würde ich die Menschen so langsam ranführen, dass irgendwas nicht stimmt, dass da irgendwann so Sachen stehen im Saturn. Das gibt es ja auch schon so auf Toast, ist ein Jesus oder so oder so fick dich, so und dann so, das kann doch kein Zufall sein irgendwie. Das wäre schon gut. Ja, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Es hat mal irgendeine, jetzt ich will eine Astronomie-Folge, aber wir haben irgendein Wissenschaftler herausgefunden, dass angenommen wir würden jetzt entschliessen, Meteoriten zu, wie heissen diese, Asteroiden zu besiedeln und darauf Ressourcen abzubauen etc. Wenn wir uns dazu entschliessen würden, dann sagen wir immer, mega teuer, mega aufwendig, ist in etwa, müsste man so viel aufwenden, wie damals die, die die Mayflower nach Amerika geschickt haben. Das Schiff, was Amerika besiedelt hat. Das ist ungefähr das Gleiche. Also sie mussten damals genauso viel aufgeben, im Verhältnis genauso viel aufwenden von dem, was sie hatten, BIP und so weiter, bis sie das machen konnten.
Das wäre in etwa vergleichbar. Schein interessant, das ist nicht so weit weg. Das erleben wir, glaube ich, auch noch.
Was bauen die denn da ab auf Asteroiden?
Pflaumen.
Da haben wir auf jeden Fall eine Menge Pflaumen. Ist auch nicht schlecht.
Pflaumkuchen ist lecker.
Pflaummus ist auch gut.
Muss aber nicht sein. Herein. Nope. Das passiert jetzt nicht. Ähm. Erzähl mal was aus deinem Privatleben. Was ist so los im Leben des Stephan Titze? Die Leute wollen mehr wissen vom Titzler. Die Leute wollen viel hören. Die Leute wollen wieder jetzt hören, Fehlkäufe und so. Ja, ja, Fehlkäufe, Magnete. Was ist so los in deinem Leben? Ich bin am Wochenende in Berlin übrigens. Ach was, gibt es ein Fantreffen? Gibt es ein Fantreffen, weiß ich nicht genau. Erfahrt selbst am 26.11. am Brandenburger Tor. Erfahrt ihr mehr. Also ich bin der, der mit dem grossen Tizelschild trägt und Regenschirm hochhält. Ich will einfach in Berlin ein bisschen die Hauptstadt auschecken, gucken, was so geht in Mitte. Einfach mehr so ein Touri-Typ. Bist du so ein Touri-Typ, so mit Sonnenbrille und dann und Fotoapparat? Nee, gar nicht eigentlich. Aber man will aber, ich kenne das ja auch, man will aber trotzdem mal die Orte gesehen haben, die auch Touristen sehen, weil die wollen da schon die coolsten Orte sehen, das ist ja die Definition so ein bisschen. Wollten wir auch machen in New York, dass wir uns einfach in so einen Bus setzen und einfach mal durch die Gegend fahren, um alles gesehen zu haben. Es ist scheiße, aber es ist schon auch cool. Ja, vor allem ist es halt sitzen, ist halt einfach das Beste, was es gibt. Du sitzt da oben, du kannst so einen Corndog reinstopfen und dann kannst du da wirklich sitzen und der fährt an allen interessanten Orten vorbei. Das Problem ist, man macht es nicht, weil man denkt, man will nicht einer von denen sein. Man will der sein, der danach coole Geschichten erzählt. Das Einzige, was einem da hilft, ist Ironie. Dass du es halt ironisch machst, aber eigentlich, dass es nur ein Vorwand ist, Alter, dass du es eigentlich nicht machen willst. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so dumm. Wurdest du mal so richtig verprügelt? Äh, nee. Wurde ich nicht. Wir haben mal in einer Folge angeteast, dass ich mal verprügelt wurde. Und es hat ein Hörer gefragt, ob ich das mal erzählen kann. Und da wir uns gerade so viel zu erzählen haben, lass uns mal kurz hinten anschieben, alle Sachen, die wir uns eben an den Kopf teilen. Und einfach mal das kurz erklären, was da passiert ist. Stephans Prügel-Story. Hier kommt sie, lang erwartet.
Es war ein... Oh nein, ich, ich, ich, Stefan. Du bist natürlich eingeladen, spannende humoristische Anleitung zu machen und Gegenfragen zu stellen. Es war ein Samstagabend, ein kühler Septemberabend. Und es war spät. Stefan war gerade auf einer Feier, ist nachts nach Hause gefahren mit dem Fahrrad. Wie alt warst du? Ungefähr, oh, siebzehn, achtzehn, fährt nach Hause mit dem Fahrrad. Also das ist die, wie gesagt, Gute Zeit? Nee, ein bisschen, ja, ungefähr. Stefan fährt mit seinem Rad nach Hause, mit dabei seine Ex-Freundin. Damals schon Ex-Freundin oder jetzt erst Ex-Freundin? Sie fahren zusammen auf dem Fahrrad von einer Party nach Hause. Ein schöner Abend, es war ein gemütlicher Abend bei einer Freundin, die, nein, keine Freundin war, einfach irgendwer hat Geburtstag gefeiert, ich werde dann da eingeladen und war dann da mit dem Rad nach Hause gefahren. Und dann plötzlich sieht man Gestalten in der Ferne. Und dann, als ich näher kam, erkannte ich sie. Der Freund meiner Ex-Freundin war da. Und der war ein Typ, das kann ich dir sagen. Der war, das war ein crazy Typ. Der war wesentlich älter, wesentlich muskulöser. Ich war so wie heute ein schlachsiger, tollpatschiger Goofy. Wir fahren daran vorbei, nachdem wir bleiben einfach stehen. Er war aber sehr eifersüchtig plötzlich, sehr sauer, offensichtlich auf mich. Und dann war er mit sehr vielen Leuten da, teilweise auch russischen Leuten. Und die hatten also Wodka-Pollen in der Hand, das war mega klischeehaftig, und dann haben die alle, waren überbetrunken, hatten alle Flaschen in der Hand, Schnapsflaschen in der Hand, waren unfassbar betrunken, und dann spüre ich nur, halte ich an, weil die Freundin halt da angehalten hat, dann habe ich auch angehalten, und ich wollte sie nach Hause bringen, und das hat den, glaube ich, zum Ausrasten gebracht, und plötzlich spüre ich nur, wie ich von hinten einfach so eine Faust genau auf meinen Kopf bekomme. Moment, wie von hinten? Ich bin quasi mit dem Fahrrad gefahren. Du bist an ihm vorbeigefahren? Das gab meine Polizeiaussage tatsächlich. Ich bin vorbeigefahren, habe so gegrüsst, hallo, bin dann stehen geblieben, habe meine Freundin gewandert, die dann da stand, weiter hinten, und mit ihm geredet hat. Und dann hat sie ihm gesagt, was Sache ist, und das will auf einer Party kommen und so. Und dann läuft er auf mich zu, habe ich aber nicht gesehen, weil ich einfach nach vorne geguckt habe, auf mein Handy geguckt habe. Läuft hinten auf mich zu und schlägt mir in die Fresse. Ich falle um von meinem Fahrrad und liege dann da auf dem Boden und denke so, was ist denn eigentlich jetzt los? Und über mir stehen halt so ganz viele russische Menschen mit Wodkaflaschen und einer
schlägt einfach auf mich ein. Aber so mit,
aber nicht so richtig mit der Faust, sondern mit so einem Handballen,
einfach auf meinem Gesicht ein, was sehr
strange war. Und dann, und dann
liegst du halt da und du weißt halt nicht, was du machen sollst und du wirst
halt massiv zu der grössten,
also du wirst so einem unmännlichsten
Wesen der Welt, die halt sagt,
nein, nein, nein, hör auf!
Und dann, irgendwann werde ich hochgezogen,
weil dann wurde auch irgendwann zurückgezogen von
denen, die haben so gegenseitig, ja, hör auf, hör auf, hör auf,
Und dann irgendwann werde ich hochgezogen, weil dann wurde auch immer zurückgezogen von denen, die haben so gegenseitig, hör auf, hör auf, hör auf, und dann wurde ich hochgehoben und wurde dann von einem, der so eine Flasche in der Hand hatte, die so quasi zum Ausholen bereit in der Hand hatte, auf die andere Strassenseite begleitet und so. Und dann hatte ich natürlich ein ganz seltsames Gespräch, an das ich mich nicht mehr erinnern kann. Und dann irgendwann hat sich das dann aufgelöst und dann sind wir weggefahren. Und ja, das war's dann. Und die Freundin ist auch mit denen mitgefahren. Nee, ist mit mir mitgefahren. Die hat sich dann dafür entschuldigt, die hat auch die ganze Zeit eingreifen wollen, aber keine Chance gehabt natürlich, weil die einfach alle auf mich drauf sind. Und dann bin ich nach Hause gefahren. Nächsten Morgen habe ich dann eine Aussage bei der Polizei gemacht, was mega gruselig ist. Also du bist einfach dann selbstständig zur Polizei gegangen? Ja, genau, mit meinem Vater damals, bin zur Polizei gegangen und habe dann meine Aussage gemacht gegen Unbekannt, beziehungsweise gegen Bekannt und Unbekannt, weil ich wusste nicht, wer die anderen waren. Und dann ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz strange. Und du denkst, sobald du bei der Polizei sitzt, denkst du, du bist schuldig. Ja.
Du hast keine Chance. Und dann stellt er auch so Fragen.
Wie, gerade eben haben sie noch gesagt, er war hinter ihnen. Wo waren sie da nochmal? Können sie nochmal von vorne anfangen?
und du denkst so,
Scheiße, vielleicht war es doch ich.
Ich habe mich selbst geschlagen.
Ich habe ihn geschlagen, ich hasse Rusten, ich habe auf sie eingeschlagen, sorry, ciao.
Du denkst echt, du bist schuldig,
weil der Kommissar Eichwald oder so war das,
der Garmener Kommissar, der dann da sass
und dann da saß und dann so ein Riesenschrank, der dich dann auch mega löchert und so, wie ein Film. Und dann ein paar Wochen später kam dann der Anruf, ich sollte mal vorbeikommen, und dann meinte er, wir haben sie alle einfach, und die haben, keine Ahnung, wie möglich das war, aber die haben alle gefunden, die da beteiligt waren.
Unfassbar gute Polizeiarbeit und so. Und dann gab es relativ schnell
einen Gerichtstermin und
dann dachte ich mir, Moment,
muss ich jetzt alleine hingehen oder hat man
dann Anwalt oder so einen Scheiß?
Es war mir nie, wo ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, ob ich einen Anwalt haben soll
und dann bin ich da alleine hin zu diesem Gerichtstermin,
muss dann auch meine Sachen abgeben.
Als Zeuge ja nur, oder? Als Zeuge, ja.
Nee, als Kläger und Zeuge.
Und dann saß ich dann da und wurde vorgeladen
und dann war dann der Angeklagte links mit seinen Anwälten und dann saß ich dann in der Mitte und dann war es der zwei Schöffen und der Richter, die mich dann so Dicke gefragt haben und so. Und das Beste war, dass ich einen Tag bevor das passiert ist mit dem Fahrrad umgekippt bin, auf so einem Schotterweg und halt meine ganzen Hände waren offen und überall waren Wunden und so ein Scheiß und es sah mega gruselig aus. Aber es hat nichts mit dem Fall zu tun gehabt, aber ich war halt mega demoliert und es war rückblickend das Beste, was mir passieren konnte, weil die dachten, holy shit, der wurde richtig verprügelt, aber so schlimm war es jetzt auch nicht, weil ich habe ein paar Mal was ins Gesicht bekommen und einmal halt von hinten, aber dann so weit
ging es eigentlich und hatte ich aber halt diese ganzen
Wunden von meinem Fahrradunfall
und die dachten, was ist denn da passiert eigentlich
und dann hat der Typ,
einer von den Angeklagten war vorbestraft und
hatte gerade einen neuen Job bekommen bei der DHL
und war so auf den Weg
der Besserung, hatte auch ein kleines Kind und
alles gut und dann saß ich da
und dann meinte der so, ja, sie hatten auch erwähnt, dass sie Nasenbluten hatten. Kommt das dann, kam das von den Schlägen ins Gesicht? Und dann habe ich so gesagt, ich wollte auch jetzt auch nicht, dass er Megaprobleme bekommt. Und dachte mir, bist du einfach ehrlich? Ich habe gesagt, ich hätte auch einen Fahrradunfall, vielleicht war das davon irgendwas. Und so hat er sich auch Notizen gemacht, der Richter und so. Und später bei der Urteilsverkündung meinte er, ja, das mit der Nase, das hat für mich den Ausschlag gemacht, offensichtlich wollen sie nicht die Schuld auf den Angeklagten übertragen, deswegen vertraue ich ihm so sehr bei der ganzen Nummer und deswegen hat er dann zwei Monate bekommen oder so im Knast, wirklich, er wurde einfach verknackt. Seinen Job hat er verloren. Und ich habe
1000 Euro Schmerzensgeld
bekommen und
100 Euro für mein Fahrrad, was
kaputt gegangen ist dabei. Und das war das.
Ich bin maximal ehrlich
da reingegangen und habe maximal dadurch
einfach ruiniert, den Menschen.
Aber der, der zwei Monate bekommen hat, der war nur
dabei, oder was? Nee, der hat auch mitgemacht, der hat auch mitgeschlagen.
Aber das war eine ganz strange Sache. Und die 1000 Euro habe ich bis heute nicht bekommen. Ist es echt, darf man das, ist es legitim, danach zu fragen? Vielleicht musst du die irgendwo in die Rechnung stellen, also keine Ahnung. Wow, nicht schlecht. Aber die ganze letzte haben geschieht, dann war ich da wirklich vor Gericht. Der Strassenfuchs Stefan Titze. Ja, das war meine willende Jugend. Noch heute raunt man seinen Namen auf den Kamener Strassen. Das ist so uncool einfach, das ist so sich verloren. Ich wehre mich dann auch nicht, ich prügel nicht zurück. Ja, ja, vor allem wenn du schon von Kampfbeginn am Boden liegst einfach. Und der Geil, hier kommt die Masterclass, vergiss die Pointe, der Typ, der Freund, der Ex-Freundin war Freestyle-Karate-Meister des Landes. Freestyle-Karate, yay! Das wusste ich, und da habe ich keinen Bock, dann daneben zu stehen und zu sagen, okay, komm, wer fängt zuerst an, komm, und dann die Fäuste ihm entgegenzustrecken. Nope, not gonna happen. Krasser Freestyle-Karate-Tipp, da hast du keine Chance. Und dann fragen natürlich auch viele, geht's dir wieder gut und so ach, manche machen sich lustig, so wurde es verprügelt, aha. Aber dann habe ich immer gesagt, ja, er ist halt, ja weißt du, er ist halt ein Freestyle-Kerate-Typ. Und ich hätte natürlich auch keine Chance gehabt und die waren zu achtzehnt, waren zu dritt oder so und ja, hast natürlich keine Chance. dann mit der Narbe im Gesicht und so diesem Pflaster im Gesicht stand ich dann da in der Bar nachts. Ja, ich wurde einfach massiv von einem Freestyle gerade, Team. Ja, war nicht schlecht. Aber sind die immer noch zusammen? Weißt du das? Nee, ich glaube nicht, nee. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein guter Moment in der Beziehung, einfach so, wo einfach jemand grundlos zusammengeschlagen wird, weil man mit denen zusammen war. Ja. Und was machen wir jetzt irgendwie? Donuts, Starbucks, worauf hast du Bock? Na, machen wir uns einen schönen Abend so. Ja, du hattest noch Blut an den Händen. Ach, kein Problem. Sorry, tut mir Sorry, tut mir leid. Ja, mega unangenehm. Es war wirklich, wirklich eine furchtbare Zeit, aber irgendwie lustig, also man die Erfahrung zu machen, so vor Gericht zu sein und so. Und das ist echt Angst. Deswegen denke ich mir auch, und die haben so massiv gut ermittelt, ich keine Ahnung, wie das möglich war, aber die haben überall rumgefragt und so sneaky Typen, die Polizisten. Das war echt ziemlich cool. Und seitdem vertraue ich dem Staat da sehr, weil die Polizei ist schon so coole Leute, die da unterwegs waren. Schon ganz interessant.
Und natürlich den Vorteil, dass in Kamel vielleicht nicht so viel los ist, dass die gesamte Taskforce einfach so, ich stelle mir so vor wie dann in dem Kommissarraum dann so dein Kopf so ganz gross, ganz viele Fäden zu ganz vielen Leuten, dann Binky sagt
Boo, Fragezeichen, da die Bandmitglieder irgendwie
ist deine Verbindung, Bandenkriege,
was kann sein, irgendwie,
Freestyle-Karate, Fragezeichen, irgendwie alles
aufgedröselt. Ja, ja, weil das das Spannendste
ist, was nicht jemals passiert ist. Ja, weil so oft
bei Law and Order oder so ist es ja so, dass der Fall
am Anfang noch recht einfach wirkt
und dann am Ende merkst du, oh shit,
da steckt viel mehr dahinter, aber dein Fall war so ein, okay, wir fangen mal an, oh cares. Da könnte viel mehr, oh, wir haben ihn schon gelöst. Ist ja nach vier Minuten vorbei und dann halt nur noch Abspann und Outtakes oder sowas. Mehr kommt dann einfach nicht mehr bei rum. Ja, gelöst. Die Zeit, die sie gebraucht hätten, diesen roten Bindfaden zu kaufen, zu schneiden und aufzuhängen, hätten sie sich wirklich ... In der Zeit war der Fall schon gelöst.
Es ist doch bestimmt schon vorgekommen, dass der Prakti mit dem Faden in das Büro gekommen ist und so,
hey Leute, ich habe den Faden! Ne, passt schon, der Fall wurde gelöst.
Okay.
Okay, ich wollte den Faden gerade aufhängen.
Machen wir beim nächsten Fall. Es kommt noch der nächste rote Fadenfall.
Wann entscheidest du dich, diesen Faden aufzuhängen?
Warum rot?
Ja, der rote Faden, der sich durch alles durchzieht. Wett auf oben. Hm, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah von Carmen knapp verloren hat. Eine Runde hat es gedauert. Eine Runde geschehen. Aber letztendlich hast du gewonnen. Ich glaube, für den 1.end Euro, wenn die jetzt kommen, kannst du dir nochmal schön ein halbes Boosted Board kaufen und dann mal den Carmina Boys zeigen, wer der König der Strasse ist. Nicht auf dem Boosted Board. Nicht auf dem brennenden Boosted Board. Lustige Geschichte, ich weiss nicht, keine Ahnung, die müssen erstmal ihr explodierende Batterienprobleme in den Griff bekommen. Aber wir haben für den Dreh, bekommen wir bald, kann ich mal teasen, einen Star Wars Helm, einen Star Wars Rebellen X-Wing Helm und ich habe die Maske, das Kostüm hatte eigentlich keine Lust, den zu kaufen, weil der zu teuer ist, ich habe gesagt, ich packe 50 Euro da drauf, wenn ihr mir den danach gebt, wenn ihr mir den danach schenkt und es ist zwar nur ein Kostümhelm, aber ratet mal, wer mit seinem Boosted Board bald mit dem coolsten Helm der Galaxie rumfährt.
Motherfucking Jungfrauen-Stefan, das war's von mir.
Viele Grüße von Florentin an euch da draußen.
Macht's gut, vielen Dank, bis nächste Woche, macht's gut, ciao!
Wir heben ab!